voilà normalement vous avez matinée de
travail et peut-être du son alors
j'espère
j'avais essayé de paramétrer les
différentes scènes mais apparemment ça
ne fonctionne pas comme je le souhaite
évidemment je me suis levé un peu trop
tard que pour régler tout ça
ok ça fonctionne ah bah désolé pour tous
les chipotages voilà les risques du
métier les conditions du direct
j'essaierai de d'améliorer ça pour la
prochaine fois super
alors on se retrouve aujourd'hui bat
pour faire des sciences sociales à
dimanche matin c'est quand même
formidable et je voulais proposer vous
proposer la lecture d'un article est ici
un article qui est peut-être un peu
sulfureux je ne sais pas ça vous de voir
si c'est un sujet politique ou pas c'est
la représentation techno genre et de
tout ce qui est lié à la technologie sur
youtube donc ici c'est un article de
l'orb holcat à bari et de marie desprès
launay qui sont des chercheuses ou des
personnes façon qui travaille aux
universités de lille et de lyon si je ne
me trompe vous allez voir plus bas c'est
indiqué et en fait elles vont vraiment
s'intéresser à ce qui se passe sur
youtube alors bon ça m'a interpellé je
trouvais ça fun pour le premier direct
qu'on allait faire ensemble de découvrir
ce type d'article alors vous voyez qu'il
vient de la plateforme al vous savez
aussi sans doute qu'il ya différentes
plateformes où on peut aller chercher
des articles scientifiques ou des
articles presque scientifique et j'ai
envie de dire que ça c'est un article
presque scientifique parce que sur al en
fait vous allez retrouver plein de de
travaux différents et des travaux qui
n'ont pas été publiés
la différence se trouve un travail
scientifique et un travail scientifique
il n'est pas encore totalement c'est la
publication dans une revue scientifique
est ici sur à l'on va retrouver les
harkis qui ne sont pas forcément publié
sur des revues scientifiques
maintenant cela étant dit vous avez cet
article 6 qui a été publié dans une
revue à comité de lecture donc on
pourrait assimiler à une revue
scientifique mais malheureusement ben
vous voyez ici en bas il est indiqué que
toute reproduction tout dit lyon était
interdite donc je ne vais pas le stream
et mais en fait le contenu est quasi
quasi le même que celui ci quoi donc ça
c'est le pré travail si vous voulez en
voir ans on va rentrer dedans tout de
suite peut-être juste regarder s'il ya
des questions désolé je vais devoir
passer d'une fenêtre à l'autre comme ça
alors vous avez toujours l'abstract
début du de l'article il ya toujours un
petit résumé qui explique de quoi il
s'agit et moi je dis souvent aux élèves
eh bien lisez l'abstract parce que vous
allez savoir si cette source elle est
intéressante si vous faites une
recherche si c'est intéressant ou pas il
faut pas tout se coltiner faut pas tout
lire cl abstract vous dit déjà que ça ne
répond pas à votre question de recherche
votre question de départ passez votre
chemin quoi alors le résumait partant du
postulat que les technologies sont
porteuses du contexte social dans lequel
elles sont conçus et utilisés nous avons
voulu évaluer le rôle que les sites de
partage de vidéos tels youtube pourrait
jouer dans la construction de modèles
identificatoires relatif à la compétence
numérique - techno genre est qu'ils ne
sont dans les médias traditionnels nous
avons analysé une série de 25 vidéos
portant sur le déballage d'un smartphone
nos premières conclusions sont que loin
de réduire cette division sexuée des
intérêts des compétences cette
présentation tendre est au contraire à
les renforcer et donc voilà on voit que
youtube finalement est un agent de
socialisation qui va dans le sens des
stéréotypes déjà présent et j'ai envie
de dire c'est la problématique qui est
peut-être la plus intéressante c'est de
se dire bah tiens youtube c'est un truc
quand même relativement moderne c'est
vraiment le média 2.0 un tout le monde
que publié donc on va avoir moins de
stéréotypes que dans des médias
mainstream qui sont souvent aujourd'hui
critiqué on dit souvent voilà les médias
mainstream il ya une seule vision du
monde qui est partagé et sur youtube ça
va être différent eh bien on se rend
compte en tout cas ici en lisant
abstraite que ça va pas être le cas
alors je tiens à dire tout de suite que
personnellement voilà ici on va parler
des stéréotypes de genre moi je suis ni
pour ni contre j'essaie toujours d'avoir
une vision très neutre des choses même
si parfois c'est compliqué sur certains
sujets mais voilà on pourrait se dire ah
tiens voilà la vidéo ici sur youtube
elle va elle va contredire et
stéréotypes on va faire du féminine nous
non pas du tout après chacun qui a les
conclusions qu'ils souhaitent de ça nous
on constate juste ce qui se passe que
youtube ne va pas être un espace qui va
combattre les stéréotypes que du
contraire c'est juste ça qu'on constate
après chacun et qui en tire les
conclusions qu'il souhaite quoi voilà si
vous êtes vous voulez mais opinion vous
m'envoyer un mail vous chatter avec moi
on en discutera mais ce n'est pas le but
ici je trouve que parfois les opinions
prennent un peu trop le dessus dans les
débats ça pas être l'objectif ici du
stream alors j'ai souligné g surligner
ce qui est plus intéressant ce que je
ferai dans les commentaires du stream
après le stream et je vous partage ray
ce document comme ça vous aurez les
éléments essentiels si ça vous intéresse
le cas échéant mais de façon vous pouvez
retrouver tout l'article sur ali a pas
de souci les filles sont en effet peu
nombreuses à s'orienter vers les
formations et les métiers du numérique
plus encore leur nombre diminue de façon
significative depuis 30 ans ou plus
précisément alors que le nombre de
femmes diplômées en informatique reste
constant la présence masculine
augmentent massivement quand les
filières se diversifie donc en fait on
nous dit souvent oui mais vous savez le
l'égalité homme femme elle va s'aguerrir
avec le temps il ya un effet de
rattrapage qui est en place ça va
arriver mais on voit ici que dans ce
domaine si pas du tout quoi n'est pas
d'égalité homme femme alors je dis pas
qu'il faut qu'il y en ait une ça encore
une fois c'est chacun se fait son avis
par rapport à ça mais en tout cas ici on
voit que c'est pas le cas c'est pas la
tendance donc c'est un peu contre
intuitif aussi isabelle collet a
notamment montré que les figures
d'informaticiens présente dans les
romans policiers ou les films de science
fiction
dès les années 90 avaient constitué des
modèles identificatoires culturellement
familles et aux garçons car conforme aux
imaginaires pour du pouvoir masculin
dans lesquelles il avait été éduqué ses
figures dont notamment celle du hacker
aurait al'inverse décourager les jeunes
filles de s'engager dans cette filière
en effet bon
l'image qu'on a dû à coeur c'est le gars
ensuite à capuche d'air son ordinateur
et c'est généralement un gars quoi c'est
généralement pas une hackeuse
partant de ce constat nous avons pensé
que les sites de partage de vidéos en
ligne pourrait constituer une
alternative éditorial intéressante par
pour la construction de figure moins
stéréotypé donc c'est ce qu'on disait
comme ça en partant de nos
représentations de ce qu'on pense comme
ça de manière intuitive on pourrait se
dire bah tiens youtube ça va être moins
stéréotypé et si elle nous dit une de
nos hypothèses de départ était que cet
espace d'auto publication relativement
libre bah oui on fait ce qu'on veut
d'ailleurs ce que je fais maintenant je
sais exactement ce que je en
publications et si vous êtes sur youtube
ou sur twitter vous faites exactement ce
que vous voulez des conditions
évidemment liés à la plateforme mais je
veux dire au niveau du contenu est
techniquement accessible pour des
amateurs pourrait permettre de
développer une parole libérée des
contraintes des sociétés de production
audiovisuelle et donc contribuer à la
construction de nouveaux modèles
identificatoires ou un techno j'aimerais
que ceux proposés par les médias
traditionnels et moi je vais vous dire
ce qui m'intéresse dans cet article
finalement quand on analyse tout ce qui
est représentation des genres dans les
médias on va vite arriver analyser les
séries analyser les films d'ailleurs
j'avais une stagiaire qui va arriver
dans une des classes de sciences
sociales où je donne cours et alors elle
avait sa com comme idée de séquences de
travailler justement sur sur ces
stéréotypes et elle allait partir des
films et des séries
et donc c'est toujours ça l'hypothèse
qu'on nous formule il ya des stéréotypes
qui se reproduisent anxiété parce qu'il
ya des images qui sont véhiculées via
les séries viallet et moi je pense que
c'est une analyse un peu simpliste que
c'est beaucoup plus comment dire
intériorisée par les individus et que
l'on reproduit même quand on est contre
les stéréotypes parfois les reproduit
aussi à l'insu de notre plein gré j'ai
envie de dire
pour les images et donc ici sur youtube
c'est exactement ça ce sont des
individus lambda qui vont alors pourquoi
ça serait sakic est intéressant de se
poser comme question pourquoi pourquoi
vont-ils reproduire des stéréotypes dans
leur production alors que voilà ils ont
aucune aucune exigence en terme de
contenu aucune contrainte ou quasi
aucune
voie là ils vont juste se conformer quoi
et ça je trouve ça mais profondément
intéressant est vraiment une
problématique première de sciences
sociales
alors ici ils vont développer un petit
elles vont développer gentiment ces gens
qui à ce niveau aussi
le concept de jeunes de gap index et les
différences entre les hommes et les
femmes tout simplement et donc on eût
dit ici alors que la maîtrise
dispositifs numériques tant du point de
vue matériel qu'intellectuel devient un
facteur important d'intégration la
reprise de la sur représentation des
hommes dans le domaine reste une réalité
sur les plans académique et
professionnelle comme sur le plan
médiatique alors outre le fond sur la
forme j'ai des choses à redire regardez
ici manque un espace après la virgule
mais ça c'est le type de détail s'est
passé pas grave ça va pas corrompre
l'ensemble du document mais c'est le
type de détails qui nous dit voilà on
n'est pas sur une peau plus une
publication parfaitement aboutie quoi
finalement dans une revue scientifique
on n'aurait pas ce genre de coquilles ou
d' erreur typographique
elles étaient encore présentes ici mais
y en a plusieurs dans tout le texte non
moins il faut des espaces ici c'est ce
qui relève qu' on n'est pas fâchés une
production a sample sont emboutis j'ai
envie de dire donc ces petits des petits
marqueur qui permettent de se dire tiens
attention c'est pas ça pas été publié ça
alors au niveau des disparités
professionnel j'ai souligné quelques
chiffres 1 27% des femmes sont salariées
du numérique donc ça veut dire que le
reste évidemment c'est des hommes ou des
dd non binaire m'enfin bon ça serait
vraiment des pourcentages très très
faible par exemple seuls 6 % exercent
des métiers de développer deux donc là
quand on est vraiment dans le hard du
numérique et de l'informatique eh bien
on n'a plus que 6 % et on voit ici mais
j'ai des questions je sais pas si vous
vous posez la même question on nous dit
que dans les années 80 le nombre de
femmes dans la filière a commencé à
décliner mais si on se renvoie dans les
années 80 alors peut-être que vous étiez
panne et moi je suis dans 79 donc
j'ai toujours aussi l'informatique
existait mais ce n'était pas non plus
comme maintenant donc je trouve ça un
peu paradoxal de dire que le nombre a
décliné on aimerait en savoir un peu
plus sur ce sur cette affirmation est ce
que c'est un taux est ce que c'est parce
que il y avait forcément moins de gens
qui travaillent dans l'informatique dans
les années 80 alors c'est peut-être une
représentation que je reproduis ici mais
ça si vous avez des idées vous pouvez
éventuellement les partager dans le chat
alors je vais voir dans le cadre s'il ya
des questions non
n'hésitez pas
alors aux états unis la part des femmes
dans les études dans l'informatique est
passé de 35 à
18 % entre 80 et 2012 donc les chiffres
sont quand même sans appel il ya
vraiment un gène de rigueur comme on le
dit ici dans l'article d'après isabelle
collet ce déclin serait concomitant avec
l'apparition des premiers ordinateurs
dans les foyers qui ceux qui sont sous
le vent installé dans la chambre du
garçon alors ça c'est intéressant moi
c'est des petites choses qui je trouve
ça vraiment intéressante parce que là on
aurait une observation tout fait d'aller
vérifier cette observation cette
affirmation est d'aller de faire une
petite enquête ou d'aller directement
chez les gens à observer et de voir s'il
ya un poste fixe maintenant évidemment
avec les portables
pardon ça a un peu évolué mais s'il ya
un poste fixe où est ce qu'ils se
trouvent et qui l'utilisent ça serait
intéressant de voir est ce que cette
affirmation parce que c'est là que se
cache finalement
l'explication c'est dans des petits
gestes à mon sens du quotidien comme
cela que finalement après on a des
différenciations en termes de
représentation par rapport à l'usagé du
numérique entre les filles et les
garçons c'est par des petits
comportements comme ça qui peuvent
paraître anodins qui fait qu'au final on
a des grosses différences à mon sens
c'est les hypothèses sont donc les
garçons qui se serait approprié
l'informatique domestique tout comme les
jeux vidéo qui serait alors devenu un
quasi monopole masculin peut-être
relativiser maintenant que j'ai
l'impression dans les jeux vidéo il ya
plus en plus de gens mais enfin bon
c'est toujours que des divisions très
partiels qu'on peut avoir des choses
mais c'est clair que pour donner un
exemple c'est un exemple c'est pas une
force de preuve mais dans les classes
généralement quand on s'en sort pas un
informatique c'est toujours un mec qui
vient un peu dépanner le prof quoi si
vous voulez
bon ici je sais pas s'il y avait encore
de l'estrie bhl mais qu'il y avait un
bon exemple
de ça mais voilà ce sont des des
exemples alors il ya des questions
justement de killian mais ce que les
proportions n'aurait pas changé par
rapport aux changements de la ligue des
champions tout à fait moi je pense en
effet ça il faudra aller un petit peu si
on voulait être vraiment très précis et
pointu il faudra aller un petit peu voir
ce cas d'isabelle colère on a sa
bibliographie
plus bas et d'aller voir un petit peu l
comment elle a travaillé ces données là
parce que ces affirmations là sont un
peu balancé ici mais en effet on peut se
demander aujourd'hui est ce que c'est
encore l'actualité de se dire ce qui n'a
pas eu un rattrapage dans ces dernières
années ah oui j'ai oublié de dire ici
l'étude je crois que celle ci ait publié
2017 2018 voilà il ya déjà trois ans qui
sont passées mais ça peut aller très
très vite donc en effet moi je pense
qu'il faut un petit peu prendre ces
chiffres avec des pincettes mais voilà
n'empêche qu'il ya quand même un
décalage ça c'est certes certains
d'ailleurs on fera après une petite à la
fin du stream on ira voir sur youtube
est-ce que les hypothèses et les
affirmations des conclusions qui sont
formulées ici est-ce qu'on peut les
vérifier nous mêmes tout de suite quoi
vous allez voir c'est assez rigolo je
trouve alors on a le stéréotype du clic
évidemment qui revient souvent et si
avec l'expansion de l'informatique puis
du numérique les emplois dans ce secteur
sont devenus de plus en plus prestigieux
bien rémunérés et donc davantage visés
par les hommes que par les femmes
donc là c'est aussi intéressant là sont
nés sur un autre une autre échelle un
autre niveau par rapport aux carrières
professionnelles
ici un autre concept que je trouvais
intéressant c'est le phénomène du tuyau
percé donc c'est à dire qu'il ya des
femmes qui bien sûr vont dans le secteur
de l'informatique et du numérique mais
elles finissent par le quitter et c'est
toujours la même histoire qui revient
c'est souvent en raison de la maternité
ou des aménagements de carrière ne sont
pas forcément prévu en tout cas c'est ce
que dit gérard valenduc et que du coup
bas la flexibilité qui est demandait
surtout dans ce secteur là il a fini par
être pénalisé ans pour les femmes donc
ça c'est aussi une autre explication qui
est intéressante et puis si on ne
propose différents facteurs qui a bien
sûr l'éducation familiale qui joue
l'orientation scolaire mais pour moi
c'est un peu une tautologie à une
tautologie c'est quelque chose qui se
répète on dit deux fois la même chose
parce que l'orientation scolaire elle
est toute façon lié à l'éducation
familiale ou en tout cas au milieu
familial dont claude est un des facteurs
qui sont très proches l'influencé
discours médiatique on a déjà beaucoup
parlé et la construction sociale du
rapport des femmes à la technique qu'ils
font tous ces factures là vont faire
qu'on va voir ce jeune de rigueur
alors sur le net que se passe-t-il les
jeunes hommes technophiles dont la
présence en ligne et notamment sur
youtube et légitimé par l'affirmation
sociale de leur maîtrise naturelle des
compétences attendues c'est ce qu'on
disait le garçon est vu comme le plus
compétent en technique les filles soto
discrimine d'ailleurs il ya des autos
stéréotypes qui agissent aussi en disant
non je n'y connais rien de ça et donc
finalement on va avoir une
surreprésentation des hommes par rapport
aux femmes alors ici on ne dit pas par
exemple dans le commune lacunes les
communautés du logiciel libre vous savez
puisque et openoffice enfin tout ce qui
est le logiciel libre et open office mer
c'est pas que de la bureautique à plat
le logiciel je crois qu'au ps aussi fait
partie de cette communauté du logiciel
libre enfin moi je ne suis pas donc je
ne peux pas trop vous en parler
j'ai lu là dessus non plus il y en a que
1 25 % des femmes et surtout les
articles wikipédia on n'a que 15 % des
femmes de placer des chiffres qui sont
quand même assez intéressant parce qu'il
ya vraiment un décalage c'est pas du 45
55 ans et du 15 85 donc c'est quand même
des gros décalage qu'on retrouve aussi
sur le net alors que le net aurait pu
être un espace de réappropriation de
réappropriation féministe j'ai envie de
dire
non seulement on a construit
sexuellement le langage de
l'informatique et du monde numérique
mais
continue de fait à en dominer les
structures grâce à une auto évaluation
de leurs compétences donc les hommes en
fait on nous dit ici que les hommes ont
vraiment fort j'ai le monde numérique
alors je vois pas très bien qu'est-ce
qui fait dans le langage informatique ce
qu'est ce qui fait que on a quelque
chose qui est plutôt pour les hommes ça
je le comprends pas il faudra l'avoir
encore ici la source qui est proposé que
cette à 2012 quoi pour en savoir un peu
plus quoi
voilà donc ça ça vous pose un petit peu
tout le contexte théorique dans lequel
l'observation va s'inscrire
l'appropriation de la productivité
physique d'une part et la conception des
machines et des procédés de l'autre ont
souvent de manière convergente
constituer les hommes comme apte et les
femmes comme inadaptée et que les hommes
détiennent les quasi monopole de la
conception de procédés technologiques et
des équipements de production voilà on
est un peu cela sur la même idée alors
avec tout ça qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
que ça qu'est ce qu'elles vont faire
hébert ici on va nous proposer un petit
peu le cadre de la méthodologie comment
vont-ils observer la chose ou vouloir
vérifier leur hypothèse parce que leurs
hypothèses de départ jusqu'à présent
c'est que youtube est un espace de
liberté dans lequel ou de semi liberté
dans lequel les femmes auraient pu se
réapproprier la technologie
la majorité des études relatives à la
place des femmes dans le secteur
numérique en france possèdent jusqu'à
aujourd'hui viatte d enquête par
questionnaire des entretiens menés
auprès des personnes qui poursuivent des
études supérieures ou qui sont déjà
insérés professionnellement ainsi que
par le biais d'analysés mieux discursif
de produits des industries culturelles
donc c'est vrai qu'on ne va jamais voir
le phénomène au plus près parce que soit
on demande aux gens de parler demain
donc il ya toujours des billets ou alors
on va regarder les discours médiatiques
mais bon voilà après
je pense que comme je le disais tout à
l'heure c'est plus compliqué que ça quoi
c'est pourquoi nous avons choisi
d'investiguer sur le web est de nous
intéresser à de jeunes vidéastes
amateurs afin d'observer comment ils et
elles mettent en scène leurs compétences
numériques est ce que les échanges lui
dans les faisceaux de des commentaires
nous disent de ses compétences telles
qu'elles sont énoncées est perçue par
les internautes alors pour moi il ya il
ya trois choses intéressantes la
première ce sont déjà des témoignages
chaque vidéo sur youtube finalement
parle de son auteur on fait voilà moi
j'aurais jamais des vidéos comme comme
dédé youtuber plus classique parce que
je suis prof et de moi je fais les
vidéos de profs et même dès que j'essaie
de faire du fun j'ai du fun de profs
s'il voulait donc c'est ainsi pour tout
le monde chacun qui parle sur sur les
réseaux sociaux bas parle de là où il
est quelque part et donc la façon dont
il va faire la vidéo ils ont donc il va
parler lui-même va nous dire beaucoup
sur lui même plus peut-être que lui ne
pensant donné quoi ça c'est la première
chose deuxième chose c'est que en tant
que créateurs de contenu les youtuber
les youtube buzz sont eux mêmes des
agents de socialisation vont eux mêmes
participé concourir à une certaine
socialisation ça c'est le deuxième
niveau est le troisième niveau bas c'est
tous les commentaires on a en plus
vraiment des réactions à chaud parfois
un peu comment dire
épidermique un peu émotionnel parfois
sur les réseaux sociaux bon parfois on
voit certains commentaires on se dit
mais là personne n'a pas réfléchi quand
elle a posté son truc donc on a aussi
des réactions en brut quelque part et
ses trois niveaux moi je les trouve très
intéressant à analyser et à observer
alors je regarde si vous demandez
quelque chose non
n'hésitez pas dans l'est dans le chatt
brucy comme j'ai eu des petits problèmes
de paramétrage et obs je sais pas voir
vos commentaires de joueurs tournés sur
la fenêtre à chaque fois mais c'est pas
grave un jv nous avons précisément
souhaité observer si les hommes
apparaissent comme plus légitime que les
femmes pour donner avis conseils aux
formations sur un outil intuitif dont
l'usagé massif et concerne autant les
hommes que les femmes le smartphone
donc là c'est intéressant pour éviter
d'oublier on va pas s'intéresser aux
derniers ordinateurs de gaming ou des
choses comme ça on va prendre vraiment
le truc que tout le monde a presque tout
le monde le smartphone nous postulons
que la construction d'une légitimité
genre et sur les technologies numériques
reposent sur les imaginaires de cette
technologie véhiculée par le contenu des
vidéos et de leurs commentaires ainsi
que sur la mise en scène des compétences
informatiques que les vidéos propose
l'analyse interroge donc la rhétorique
des vidéos on va regarder les discours
la gestuelle l'insertion d'image les
musiques le texte dont nous voient pas
rire tout ça on va rester sur des
conclusions au premier un petit peu se
promener sur youtube voir ce que ça
donne mais voyez c'est assez complet on
sait faire certaines choses et des
commentaires killer qui leur sont
associées à la fois le niveau de langage
lexique utilisés ou les marqueurs
énonciatif comment les gens formule-t-il
ce qu'ils ont à dire et qu'est ce qu'ils
disent
voilà ça a lancé
en même temps par dont j'entendais
la vidéo en double voilà
elle repose également sur la mise en
regard de ses productions avec les
profils des youtuber youtube heuzé la
manière dont ils ont construit énonce
leur identité numérique nous nous
appuyons en outre sur des éléments
quantitatifs tels que le nombre de vues
le nombre d'abonnés à la chaîne le
nombre de commentaires le ratio hommes
femmes parmi les youtuber et
commentateurs commentatrice identifiés
par les marqueurs linguistique et
visuels de féminité et masculin muscles
masculinité pardon associés à leur
profil et leur discours
donc en fait souvent par le pseudo qui
est utilisée ou par le petit inventaire
et bien on sait déjà dire si on est face
à un garçon ou une fille alors ça on
aimerait en savoir un petit peu plus
parce que
j'ai des doutes parfois aussi commenté
ce qu on peut être sûr à 100% qu'il
s'agit d'un crime ou d'un garçon voilà
ça c'est un petit un petit une petite
zone nombre dans l'observation qui
propose ici
donc l'objet de l'observation ça va être
le déballage des tests de l'iphone cette
puisqu'à l'époque l'iphone set était le
truc
le smartphone à la mode septembre 2006
février 2017 25 vidéos 26 youtuber
youtube s est quand même 13 1430
commentaires analyses et
alors qu'est ce qu'on y voit d'abord sur
les 25 vidéos 10 met en scène une jeune
femme ou une adolescente la proportion
est pas si mauvaise que ça mais ce qui
est déjà intéressant c'est que c'est
ces vidéos sont réalisées par des
youtube youtube buzz pardon mode beauté
lifestyle est donc là il ya déjà un
décalage entre les hommes et les femmes
entre les vidéos dogues mais les deux
vidéos de femmes c'est que les filles ça
est plutôt la tendance laïque salle
lifestyle pardon et chez les hommes
savaient plus tôt de vidéo high tech
donc même si on parle du smartphone 10
22 10 et 15 10 filles 15 garçons eh bien
on va avoir un décalage qualitatif
j'ai pas qualitatif en termes du monde
valeur mais je garde c'est pas la même
qualité que dans le sens où c'est pas
les mêmes choses qui sont traités les
productions féminine situe l'achat et la
présentation du téléphone parmi un
ensemble d'ajax d'accessoires de mode
lee et donc on consumérisme et à une
forme de superficialité socialement
ratages et à la féminité et donc voilà
on va voir du déballage de smartphones
présentation du smartphone se son côté
esthétique commence à peu avec mon style
tiens comme ans après avec mon
maquillage que ces gens m'abordent j'ai
pas vu ces vidéos j'imagine que c'est un
peu ça c'est tout à fait autre chose que
les productions masculine qui sont plus
matures déjà en raison de l'âge des
vidéastes les vidéastes sont beaucoup
plus âgés et donc filmé de manière plus
professionnelle
observe comment tu es critique le
produit en détail et sous ses aspects
techniques leurs auteurs se situe ainsi
dans le domaine de la réflexion de la
connaissance et de l' expertise
technique et donc on pourrait se dire
c'est des interprétations mais que les
filles c'est surtout des adolescentes
des jeunes adolescentes qui font les
vidéos de présentation de smartphones et
avec l'âge mais finalement les femmes ne
se sentent de moins en moins légitime
pour parler du smartphone et donc on a
la proportion de mecs qui s'élargit et
on à la disparition des youtube
féminines c'est aussi ça que ça veut
dire parce qu'il ya cette question de
l'âge qui est aussi très présent
chez les youtube us le smartphone l'essm
le smartphone apparaissent voiliers a
des idées déco clients surtout comme un
accessoire c'est avant tout son
esthétique qui est commentée et les cris
et soupirs d'admiration ne sont pas les
freiner alors qu'ils sont exclus ou plus
musées et chez les garçons on est dans
l'émotionnel dans les vidéos de filles
alors que chez les garçons on est chez
duras yonne du don du rationnel bonjour
les clichés quoi on y est
plusieurs d'entre elles précisent
qu'elles n'ont pas l'habitude de faire
des vidéos techniques donc elles
assument leur incompétence culturel
c'est une sorte de violence symbolique
pour ceux qui connaissent brudieux et au
passage aujourd'hui 20e anniversaire de
la disparition de pierre bourdieu voilà
c'est dit il ya un superbe bouquet
sortie qui se fait 800 pages qui reprend
toutes des publications qui l'a fait sur
la théorie des champs alors je ne sais
pas si je vous le conseille parce que
voilà c'est du bruit je ne sais pas où
vous en êtes dans la découverte des
sciences sociales mais voilà petit clin
d'oeil au passage mais c'est de la
violence symbolique parce qu'elles
assument leur domination enfin leur
domination le fait qu'elle soit dominé
on est en plein dedans plusieurs d'entre
elles précisent qu'elles n'ont pas
l'habitude de faire des vidéos
techniques et se met en scène dans des
décors très construit et associés à la
féminité le maquillage les coiffures
sont soignés des couleurs pastel les
bougies les bouquets de fleurs alors il
ya une petite illustration qui nous est
proposé ici un voyant l'illustration de
avec le décor très girly très féminin et
puis le truc de geek ici un le garrec
son pull google alors c'est un peu
caricatural est généralement dans l'est
dans une publication scientifique on ne
retrouve pas de photo comme ça enfin je
dis bien en général mais c'est vraiment
caricatural assez vraiment va jaillir du
pur plaisir baisse parce que moi j'adore
les sciences sociales
voilà on est en plein en plein dans la
construction stéréotypé chez les utah
les youtube heures quand les vidéos ne
sont pas tournés dans un environnement
totalement neutre s'identifie s'envoler
la table blanche le truc très épuré ces
derniers ce film dans des décors
naturels leurs chambres 1 bureau 1 park
le contenu de leurs vidéos concerne
uniquement l'iphone sans aucune
discrétion digression sur un sujet
quelconque ou d'éléments concernant leur
vie privée en intérieur on retrouve très
souvent les signes d'un intérêt pour la
chose informatique à l'arrière-plan des
personnages de jeux vidéo des
ordinateurs de dernière génération des
accessoires high-tech des figurines de
collection de posters de films des
tee-shirt de geek comme on l'a vu ici
moi ça me fait penser que ça serait
super chouette de faire une observation
comme ça sur les décors de youtube
heures j'ai un peu cherché sur le net
pour voir s'il y avait quelqu'un qui
avait déjà travaillé là dessus mais voir
un petit peu et c'est de croiser
l'origine sociale d'un youtube heures et
de voir un petit peu ce qui nous met
dans son décor ce serait super je trouve
intéressant enfin moi ça n'intéressera à
mort
si un jour on a plus d'ambition sur
cette chaîne où j'ai pas des
collaborations sont possibles ça serait
vraiment sympa avec l'ensemble des gens
qui suivent la chaîne est bien de faire
une grande observations comme sa grande
enquête comme ça sur youtube ça ce
serait vraiment rock'n'roll je trouve
alors on le dit aussi la gestuelle des
youtuber se résume en effet dans notre
corpus à des gestes techniques efficaces
alors que celle de youtube buzz est
particulièrement riche en expressions
ritualisé de la féminité alors on pourra
les voir un petit peu ce que dubai
l'aise en 2010 est là dessus quelles
sont ces fameuses expression ritualisé
de la féminité mais on imagine bien
voilà des comportements des attitudes
totalement différente c'est en effet
uniquement parmi les youtuber que l'on
trouve des vidéotests les youtube us ne
propose que des déballages de leur
nouvel iphone et lorsqu'elle donne un
avis technique elles précisent qu'elles
ont vérifié sur le web
donc voilà si elle donne peu de
caractéristiques directement elles vont
assumer leur incompétence un supposé
parce que peut-être qu'elles sont
compétents mais elle se suppose
incompétente en disant ah oui mais ça
vient de tels sites quad auquel ne
peuvent tirer aucune légitimité
technique d'elle-même
ainsi par exemple une des innovations
apportées par le smartphone dont tous
parlé la suppression de la prise jack
apparemment dans ce nouvel iphone ça
c'était vraiment la révolution et chez
les garçons même si tous ne l'appelle
pas un cil certains disent la prise
casque alors que moi là moi qui les
filles hésitent ou utilisent des
périphrases en s'excusant de ne pas trop
savoir comment cette fameuse prise
s'appelle voilà ben si vous n'avez pas
la prise jack c'est là où on met son
casque
généralement et bien voilà le fait de
parler de cette prise jack est
particulièrement révélateur de la
différence de compétences supposées ou
réelles des filles et les garçons qui
parle de ce monde ce smartphone
marina commande par exemple la vidéo de
julie en lui rappelant que le bouton
pour les et culteurs s'appelle la prise
jack mais sinon bonne vidéo quoi donc
dans les commentaires on verra après
dans les commentaires des vidéos de
filles on n'hésite pas à bien appuyé sur
le fait qu'elles sont incompétentes au
niveau de la technique comme c'est ici
voilà c'est une bonne vidéo mettait
juste c'est juste une brêle au niveau
technologie est juste nul au niveau
technologique c'est un peu ce que ça
veut dire ce commentaire
alors question de la légitimité on est
en plein dedans on en discute déjà
depuis un certain temps de prime abord
on constate que les vidéos de youtube
buzz sont quasi-exclusivement commentées
par des jeunes filles donc on sait un
même des commentaires et aussi une
gender gap si on peut lire les vidéos
masculine ont quant à elles un réseau de
commentateurs plus mixtes même si les
commentaires me commande commentaires
parents restent majoritairement masculin
alors ici à des échanges
on en parle un petit peu c'est un peu
anecdotique cependant si les garçons
sont souvent encouragés par leur père à
progresser dans le montage la prise de
vue donc là il va y avoir des petits
conseils par rapport à la réalisation
même de la vidéo les filles ne reçoivent
que peu de conseils d'amélioration donc
il ya vraiment aussi une différence
qualitative dans les commentaires
ces conseils émane de jeunes filles et
sont généralement accompagnées d'un
compliments sur la beauté de la youtube
buzz dans les commentaires de youtube
buzz c'est plutôt encore une fois la
forme esthétique et physique le
lifestyle qui est commentée et non pas
le le fond la vidéo si vous voulez qui
est la présentation de smartphones les
compétences numériques des femmes
lorsqu'elles sont abordés sont
systématiquement dénigré voilà dès qu'il
ya un commentaire sur la maîtrise
technique de la femme c'est négatif
sous la vidéo de jeux jeunes
lorsqu'un internaute écrit qu'elle ne
comprend pas le vocabulaire employé un
abonné lui réponds oui c'est normal ça
parle de make up de cuisine ou de ménage
le fait de filmer des vidéos de
déballage l'instar de youtube heures
officiellement spécialisée dans la
technologie numérique engendre un
violent rejet des concurrents et leur
public donc on va voir les gens qui sont
plutôt habitués à aller vers des chaînes
de techniques de présentation vraiment
de la technologie vont arriver sur ces
vidéos de présentation et là c'est le
tire au bazooka
qui se fait sentir c'est souvent le cas
parfois vous avez différents champs sur
youtube qui se rencontrent par exemple
du chant basse colère avec du champ
idéologique des gens qui font
d'idéologie aidé par exemple des des
gens qui veulent présenter juste bas un
truc en sciences sociales par exemple on
va assister menthe et systématiquement
avoir un combat comme ça dans les
commentaires
sas est observable aussi sous la vidéo
de 99 vlok 99 blocks un commentateur
écrit c'est ridicule cette nouvelle
tendance des youtube euse 2.0
superficielle qui aiment se la raconter
voyez il ya encore des fautes
d'orthographe sur youtube pour des laïcs
des vues et du fric ne met pas une
boxing dans le titre car cette vidéo
n'était pas un déballage tout voulais
juste montrer que tu as un smartphone en
faisant passer ça pour un déballage
laisse les vrais youtuber
profère d box inc voilà ça c'est ça
c'est cash mais ça révèle bien voilà on
renforce le stéréotype vous êtes nul en
nul en
technologies voilà arrête de faire ce à
quoi est donc chasse gardée pour les
gens qui ont une légitimité entre
guillemets
voilà et on constate que c'est
principalement les youtube buzz qui ont
bloqué les commentaires on peut se dire
pourquoi un seul pour rappel sur youtube
vous pouvez bloquer les commentaires que
d'une seule vidéo donc si une vidéo qui
est trop polémique vous pouvez sabrer
dans les commentaires ce niveau-là ou
carrément les désactiver ce n'est que
dans les commentaires des vidéos
masculine que des questions techniques
et pratiques sont soulevés voilà encore
une fois une un décalage de qualité
entre les deux types de commentaires
ange paradis écrit par exemple dans une
vidéo comme ça de technique écrivez vos
textes beaucoup trop d'improvisation
c'est dommage le cul hd n'apporte pas
grand chose de plus voire rien en dehors
de la réalité virtuelle et bordures les
gars pas buzzell svp moi je comprends
bien pas tout mais voilà le genre de
commentaires beaucoup plus technique
beaucoup plus précis - dans le jugement
de valeur qu'on va apporter dans ses
commentaires et aucun de ceux des
commentaires de ce type ne se retrouvent
sous les vidéos de jeunes filles
et bien voilà c'est déjà pas mal de
choses qui ont été dites à ce niveau ci
est ici on va rentrer le bal vraiment
dans les modèles identificatoires
on nous dit en fait que le smartphone va
être considéré comme une pièce
d'accessoires c'est comme on l'avait dit
en tout cas chez les youtube et youtube
on s'identifie donc à des personnalités
comme les people ou les actrices elles
vont surtout singer les allées les
grandes les grands influenceurs
finalement une monde de la beauté
donc on a aussi une différence dans la
réappropriation j'ai envie de dire on
est plutôt sur la limitation d'un côté
où il ya plus de peut-être d'originalité
chez les youtuber les youtuber de leur
côté adopté une posture plus distantes
laisse peu de chose de leur vie privée
et transparaître et affiche beaucoup
moins de marques d'affect il s'identifie
plus tôt à des geeks passionnés par les
technologies possédant de solides
connaissances sur le sujet et dont la
proximité mesuré avec leur public permet
de maintenir le statut d'expert voir
d'enseignants la viralité des vidéos
favorise un mimétisme des comportements
de youtube heuzé youtuber les très
jeunes youtube us boat est reprennent
les codes de leurs aînés concerne les
choix de cadrage des vidéos la mise en
scène des produits et donc on va avoir
un grand conformisme en fait dans la
forme aussi des vidéos
ça fait un peu peur parce que voilà
c'est un peu ce qui sous-tend de
sous-entendus dans l'article là je suis
un peu dans le normatif mais voilà vous
avez un espace de liberté comme youtube
et on se rend compte que les jambes sont
des as disciplinaire reproduire des
modèles et moi même sur ma chaîne
parfois je me dis mais arrête de faire
ça parce que tu reproduit des modèles tu
dois ne pas faire ça parce que chacun
chacun fait son truc dans son coin et
c'est très bien comme ça mais il ya il
ya beaucoup de chaînes aussi qui vont
qui donne des conseils aux youtuber donc
les youtuber vont voir ça et finalement
on a une reproduction de différents
modèles quoi il retourne en cercle clos
le maquillage et les décors sont soignés
les routines langagière bienvenue sur ma
chaîne n'hésitez pas à liker ma vidéo
c'est des trucs qu'on va retrouver bien
sûr des limites qu'on va retrouver comme
ça des codes youtube qu'on va retrouver
dans ses vidéos ses vidéos offrent donc
des modèles identificatoires très
stéréotypé à la fois au niveau du genre
mais aussi au niveau de la forme en
général et regardez ici c'est ce qu'on
dit aussi dans l'article c'est la
comparaison de couleurs des smartphones
1 on va avoir des smartphones très girly
qui vont être présentés dans la vidéo de
youtube tandis qu'on va voir des vidéos
de mecs avec des smartphones très neutre
dans les tons
on arrive aux conclusions l'une des
hypothèses sur laquelle repose analyses
présentées dans cette communication
était que le site les sites de partage
de vidéos en ligne offrait des espaces
d'expression aujourd'hui largement
investi par le plus grand nombre et qui
pourrait contribuer à participer à la
construction de nouveaux modèles
identificatoires moins techno genre et
que ceux qui sont généralement véhiculée
par les médias mainstream cette
hypothèse
s'est retrouvée totalement contredite
par notre étude pour les raisons qu'on a
un peu évoqué hawaï et c'est un peu
c'est un peu un léger comme article
c'est plutôt en fait le compte rendu
d'une communication qui a été faite lors
d'une conférence mais l'article keith
ici qui est censé être l'article plus
scientifique pour moi n'est pas beaucoup
plus pas beaucoup plus étayée alors
voilà après je ne suis pas dans le
secret des dieux je sais pas du tout
comment ça a été fait je veux pas
critiquer les deux autres is de ceux de
cette étude je veux dire voilà il ya des
articles scientifiques sont beaucoup
plus dense comme par exemple celui qu'on
avait découvert la semaine dernière
alors ici qui lient à nos demandes
est-ce qu'ils prennent en compte le
sujet de base de la chaîne en question
non justement l'idée c'est de partir de
faire on va le faire ensemble
on va aller sur youtube ensemble
regardez ce que ce qu'on trouve dans
l'idée ce n'est pas de regarder
justement le la chaîne le départ c'est
de regarder l'objet le smartphone qui
est un objet du quotidien
que tout le monde utilise et qui en
parle sur youtube et comment on en parle
sur youtube alors forcément après on
arrive sur des chaînes de lifestyle et
déchets de
techno techno geek je dis ça comme ça
évidemment mais c'était pas salsa le
butin parce que l'idée c'est de partir
du smartphone comme outil qui est
utilisé par tout le monde et qui en
parle et on voit qu'il ya une différence
le discours
alors j'espère que vous êtes sûr
sur le même écran que moi
je vais retourner dans obs
normalement ça devrait fonctionner
donc là sur youtube on peut un peu on
peut essayer on va taper iphone on va
voir ce qu'on trou
après on pourrait faire le même genre
d'exercice tactique toc moi je connais
pas trop techtoc mais est-ce que sur tik
tok on retrouve des stéréotypes comme ça
par rapport à un objet du quotidien
technologique alors ici voilà ici on
retrouve là le
le geek ouais c'est un peu ça avec des
petites led et tout ça dans c'est ce
qu'on nous dit dans l'intérieur
voilà encore un mec
voilà globalement on trouve pas le
lifestyle alors ça c'est un peu plus
lifestyle mec peut-être
ça c'est l'évolution des smartphones
on retrouve quand même assez bien à ici
il ya une fille
a des couleurs un peu plus j'aurais dit
des couleurs un peu plus girly et dans
les pastels dans l'eros mais c'est un
mec au final c'est que des mecs en tout
cas lorsque je trouve alors si on va
dans la navigation privée même si
j'ouvre une fenêtre de navigation privée
est-ce que ça va fonctionner on va les
voir
c'est peut-être moi aussi qui a dévié
par rapport à mon profil
on retrouve les mêmes alors peut-être
sais pas comment ça fonctionne
c'est peut-être avec l'adresse ip
identifie à voilà shopping rentrée avec
les soeurs moi je tapais iphone
c'est quand même voilà très très très
très mais qu'un
c'est la même qui est qu'elle est déjà
que sa soeur annonce pas la même
on retrouve un petit peu cette
différence
et bien voilà voilà des idées de
recherche je pense que voilà c'est un
bon sujet
approfondir si vous devez faire de
travaux dans vos cours si vous voulez
vous amuser faire une vidéo aussi vous
même je pense que ça peut être
vraiment très amusant de travailler là
dessus alors est ce qu'il ya des
questions je veux revenir sur mon écran
ici
non je vois qu'il ya pas de questions
alors vous êtes encore quatre ans
visionnage basset c'est sympa un moment
je vois ici l'écran je sais pas s'il est
un jour je réactualise et
manu se déploie en commentaire voilà
vous êtes encore 4 apparemment c'est
sympa pour une première n'hésitez pas à
proposer des choses j'essaierai
d'améliorer la technique prochaine fois
on verra quand est-ce qu'on enfin faut
déjà que je trouve un article
intéressant la façon je publie à l'avant
sur youtube comme ça vous avez la date
si ça vous intéresse je vous souhaite un
bon dimanche et je vous dis à très
bientôt salut salut